[Music]
Brandon Marshall joining us
the official social media correspondent
for eight tMT's audience sports and
audience networks done a great job this
week did a great job last year he's
doing stuff for a lot of the programs
here and showed up yesterday right at
the end of the show when Deion Sanders
came on and it was it was so funny that
you came out of nowhere where dealings
gonna race us and then all of a sudden
you go hey I'm ready and I thought okay
this will be great Dion's gonna race
Brandon Marshall and then I thought if
you lose to Deion Sanders you'll never
hear the end of it oh my gosh listen
Deon did what only Deion can do he was
scared to death he knew he was gonna
lose but he talked his way out of it and
still looked like primetime like he just
made me look bad that guy's awesome man
do you think you would have beaten him
in a 40-yard oh absolutely I would have
beat him running back well when he said
when he said listen I have nothing to
lose I thought about my college days
there was a Titan by the name of Darcy
Johnson who lined up against me and beat
me and I still here to this day still
here to this day and that's it that's
what he said to me after he said man I
had nothing to lose let's go yeah I
don't want to experience that again
let's bring out Dorsey Johnson here you
honestly think you could beat Deion
Sanders okay let's go around the room
here yes
McLovin you got brandon marshall or you
got Deon
I got Brandon thank you you're a phony
thank you
seaton Brandon all day I'm taking diem
because I saw you warming up and you
look at me like I'm not racing anybody I
was there with you I think Deion I think
get me a 40 and a 40 yeah I think I get
me in a 40 or 100 or 200 hey man father
Tom's undefeated father time is
undefeated and that's what's wrong with
our old heads man that's what we call
those like we had to snatch the jersey
off a dealings back but he's went on to
do some great things on television and
that's why he made me look bad yesterday
on yourself it was interesting how he
was giving you this mind game where he
was saying you know like I'm already in
his head he knows I'm in his head he
doesn't want a race you know and then I
thought it felt almost like it was a
boxing press conference yeah
where he was doing his Muhammad Ali
what's the best part of all of this
because I know that you're transitioning
yeah I don't know how much longer you
play but you're transitioning into doing
something in the media yeah where do you
see yourself five years from now well
I'm already doing it well obviously in
five years I may not be playing football
anymore so I'll be full time with the
things that I'm doing outside of
football which is television and I do
love radio I I mean I feel like radio
gives you more time to talk and and it
just I just feel free on the radio so I
may make some headlines there my
foundation my Pat McAfee thing and just
walk away from the Jets and no no no no
I there I'm like what I was saying about
Deion they'd rather pull the jerseys off
my ball they will yeah yeah yeah I'm
gonna be running like a five flat and
like no I still got it
but explain you know Calvin Johnson just
walks away you know every guy's
different yeah I think it comes down to
your mentality and your psyche there
comes a point where you had enough it's
painful to play football it takes a
really special person to say you know
what I'm gonna run 40 yards full speed
out of four for 40 and run into that
brick wall right there
it's tough you know I commend him for it
you know and I call guys like that bowl
because we've been playing this sport
since we were six years old
seven years old that's all we really
know and I think that's why the
transition foremost is so difficult they
say 80% of our guys are broken you know
have marital issues and it's because we
were put on this pedestal
our entire careers our entire lives and
saying that's all you are as a football
player so you know how scary that is to
say you know what it's I'm done and you
have nothing else to do that's tough
Randy Marsh with the Jets joining us
here if you could you ever be a patriot
I think everybody could be a P we are
all Patriots well could you be a New
England Patriot oh man with the Jets
[Music]
some good footage
no you never know what can happen at the
NFL stands for what have you done for me
lately and you know things style from a
personality wise to fit in to their you
know they they tell you to fit into
their style when you think about this
and even our biggest stars our biggest
divas in the NFL in sports what do we
all have in common structure and
discipline from the age of five and six
or put on these teams and we're told
what they do we love we love structure
we love discipline that's why you see a
guy like Martellus Bennett who's been on
a few different teams like myself and
people say well man he's too opinionated
but he goes and he fits in and in any
and it works because he knows that that
coach and those in those players on that
team they have the credibility they work
hard and they're gonna win so could you
be a patriot oh well you know well how
this works you can keep talking but if
you don't give me an answer I got to ask
you you know I can be a patriot I could
be a different Bronco I can be what you
were you can't control where the NFL
sends you this was a simple question
no I cannot be a pitcher okay there
that's all yeah you if you're Malcolm
Butler yes which Malcolm Butler's role
here on Sunday continued to do it with
what he's been doing all year he's a
disrupter the thing I love about Malcolm
Butler is that he's probably one of the
toughest guys and are in the NFL and
he's really really really good see the
the year before I didn't get a chance to
play again so we played against the
Patriots twice a year I didn't get a
chance to play with him what they did is
they put him on our on Eric Decker our
number two receiver then they doubled me
when Logan Ryan and they had Devin Devin
McCourty over top and I was the whole
game well this year they let him play
one-on-one against me and I was like
well this guy's too little but he plays
like he's six five I remember one time I
caught a 20 yard in cut and I got smooth
like I caught it and then out of nowhere
he just came hitting me boom I ran off
the field went the coast boys like man
that guy can play but the thing about
why do you talk to him at all yeah I do
what I do but what kind of talk respect
well well it's funny he's a funny guy
man he just these he's one of those
passing it guys you know you'll tell him
I'm about to take the top off meaning
I'm gonna run and go out and do a Randy
Moss on your head and he's gonna laugh
and say just bring it let's go but the
thing about him is he'll give up a big
play
you know he will give a big big play
he'll give up a go or a slam for maybe
40 yards but he's gonna come right back
in your face that's the difference
between him and most corners in the
league if he gives up a big plate he
forgets about it's over he's on to the
next and that's what makes him special
can he cover Julio Jones one-on-one yes
he can't cover Julio Jones 101 but like
I said he's going to give up not only
one big play but a few big but he's
gonna make a big play he's gonna but
then he's gonna make a big play and he
balances out and he's a special talent
and it wasn't until this year where I
got a chance to matchup against him
we're understood all of the hoopla
around him Seton is the same height this
Malcolm Butler are you and you're about
the same size as Julio Jones aren't you
you may be taller didn't okay stand up
Seaton come over here and stand up next
to Brenton so just give the audience an
idea of what its gonna be like on Super
Bowl Sunday so hope yeah so who you got
yeah yeah yep yeah that separation and
NFL right there some people think okay
I've run the route boom I'm out I need a
couple of yards of separation no you
just need this I'm running out cut the
ball needs to be here where's the camera
they're all over the place yeah they'll
find you don't find you this is Julio
Jones hand the balls come in this way
that's all you need that's all the
separation you need an NFL that's it you
don't need four or five yards that's it
use your microphone there all right
there you go
so uh do you have a pick for the game I
do you look who are you gonna the
Patriots is going to win it 31 27 Wow
yeah so you can separate the fact that
you hate the Patriots but as an analyst
you can say this and say well I just I
just knew coming to Super Bowl weekend
that's the biggest question they ask all
of us and I just didn't want to go
through what we went through about can't
I be a patriot so I want to give you a
pic if you could catch a pass from Brady
or Matt running oh man Tom Brady I mean
he's the go he's the best but Matt Ryan
is he's gonna in probably uh the same
way Brady's going in he's gonna end up
well he's gonna be the MVP this year he
is the MVP right but with Brady do you
think can he be the greatest football
player of all time no no way
well wait wait wait wait wait why not
are you serious look at this
well he's in shape now but when he first
came to NFL and that's the image I see
you know when we talk about like Oh best
football player no you have Jerry Rice
you have Reggie ye you have JJ Watt yeah
there's some great football players out
there okay so Paulie stand up a guy in
this kind of football shape like that's
what way
that's what Brady looked like when he
first came in exactly yeah that's that's
the before no he's the greatest
quarterback and that's a difference and
don't get it twisted wait because he's
not a great athlete he can't be the
greatest player of all time no when I
when I think a football player I think
of football player to me means a guy
that I can plug anywhere on the field I
think of high school football I think
about a guy who can go on off at the
side and play running back wide receiver
I think about a guy who can go on a
defense inside and can play safety
corner defensive end
maybe a little linebacker that's what I
think about that's the the max in and in
in in in Oakland that's JJ Watt he can
play tight in there's some great guys
there's wide receivers out there that
can play corners you know football is
not just about one position are you a
greater football player than Tom Brady I
don't want to make any news this week
Tom Brady stays right now because I
can't wait for sure next year against
the Jets Brady's gonna be lighting you
guys up he's gonna say you like me now
what do you think of this athlete over
here Brandon yeah bunk Oh Brady treating
me good he does he treats me good he
gives me a look oh my god Tom Brady
looked at me wait what what's that mean
is he giving like the same look at Gibbs
Gisele is like what's this look like hey
they're in love
they are like no this is real love like
you know when you go out to dinner and
you maybe you see some a married couple
sitting there and they don't talk at all
and it's awkward is like oh that's what
marriage is
right so I had an opportunity to be
around Giselle and Tom last Super Bowl
we were too sweet together and I promise
you they couldn't keep their hands off
each other
they were all over each I was like man
go get a room he only baby I love you I
love you like oh my gosh
this guy was that too much information
no ok it was awesome that's what makes
you if you do store in this business
then Brandon thank you thank you for
having you every Super Bowl ran DiMarco
the Jets until he ends up signing with
the Patriots the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]